[Music]
okay everybody i'm really really excited
today
because i am being joined by the legend
himself
christian condrey how you doing today
christian i'm great
i'm doing great so everyone who's
watching this
interview please make sure you watch the
full season of sweet tooth and then come
back because we're going to be talking
some spoilers here
um so christian i absolutely loved your
relationship with jeopard in this show
i think you and nunzo had such a great
chemistry
with that being such an important
storyline did you guys have to rehearse
a lot to make sure you got
your chemistry right or that come just
like naturally on set
that really came naturally because we
never did a table read together and we
never did a chemistry read so
it was just natural and we just met each
other and it felt like we had this
instant connection we just instantly
bonded
and i felt like we knew each other for
years now we've been friends
and you know offset we we did activities
together which i also thought really
helped our chemistry
you know getting to film eight episodes
with him was such an amazing experience
because you know he's so talented and i
look up to him and i take different
tips and tricks from him and i can
incorporate that into my scenes too
so working with nanzo was amazing
yeah no that's that's great and it's
interesting too because that character
of jeopard in its relationship
to gus by the end of the season you know
he comes around to him
and i thought it was so interesting too
that he's helping him
gus's troubles through this line he says
if science created me then i don't have
a mom or dad
right do you think gus then finding out
this truth about his origin will change
him forever going forward in the show
um i think
gus is going to be you know the same
cheerful dear boy he is
always the same looking for his mom
going on an adventure with his friends
i think that it changes him during that
moment
but i think he stays strong and you know
he pushes through with his
hopeful heart and
i think he's gonna be that nice dear boy
that you know
as a gus no for sure and
in your portrayal of gus where did that
kind of stem from for you did you read
the comics beforehand to prepare or did
it kind of come straight from the script
so part of it came straight from the
script and part of it came from the
comic books
so i read all the comic books by jeff
lemire
many multiple multiple times and learned
so much from them about guts
and my fellow characters in the comic
and i really felt like i could bring
that alive on the big screen
and you know i learned so much from this
experience is playing gus
you know because i've never played such
a unique role or dear part human
and you know getting to
see all the hard work that me and my
fellow castmates you know put into the
show
on the big screen is just so amazing and
all the production team
it's amazing to see how we brought it
alive
so how serious do you take your process
as an actor like do you
go outside and watch deer to get that
deer part of it down or
you're not that crazy about it don't
live in an area that has many deer
we live more in the city so you know i
couldn't really just go
and look at deers we had to watch videos
on youtube and we
figured out how deers move and act and
you know react
and i felt like it was so awesome
getting to learn about deers and getting
to do park
war training for sweet tooth which was
pretty awesome too
and getting to do that was the most
amazing
experience ever because you know here i
am
talking to you about sweet tooth so it's
amazing
that's awesome man and you kill it so
you do this role so good
and what i wonder watching and i think a
lot of people is i love about your
character is the moving ears
was that how did that operate like was
that difficult to work with to time your
emotions with those ears moving like how
did that happen on set
so you know you see this thing right
here
yeah that is a mold of my head and what
a mold is
is basically where you sit in a chair
and well
okay so it all started with me flying to
la i sat down in the chair and i got a
mold so they put
layers of paste all over your face and
shoulders
and they can use that as a mold of you
and to um
what that mold is used for is for making
a skull cap
we'll just call that oh no it's called
cats
um the skullcap has two little magnetic
stubs on it
and because the antlers are magnetic
they can
attach and de-attach to the skull cap
which is pretty cool
and also the years on the skullcap is
remote controlled by a puppeteer who
sits the camera and watches me
and i really love the aspect of you know
how we have to
work together to really make gus and his
dear aspects come alive
yeah no and it's it's probably the
coolest part about the show
now going deeper into the character of
gus how much
of christian did you find in gus
i found literally everything in common
with me
wow well except that he's a deer we are
the exact same
love running around both of jumping we
both
love sour gummies those are the best
and we love nature and we just
love meeting new people so i feel like
me and gus have a lot in common which
really helped you know bring it out onto
the big screen speaking of the big
screen you know
sweet tooth is about a virus that sends
the world sparkling into chaos and
a new thing called hybrids emerge and
hybrids are
part human and part animal and we focus
on gus who's power deer per boy and
he lives in the woods secluded with his
father until he unexpectedly meets a
wandering loner named shepard
and then together you know they set out
on adventure about
family friendship hope to find you know
gus's origin and for jeopard to redeem
his dark past you know
while at the same time
just making offset
we're just realizing how
you know we're making sweet tooth come
alive and
i love the aspect of how you know we're
so free like the director jim mickel
he's really nice and he's such a great
director because you know he gives such
amazing directions
and he he makes it so amazing and simple
to understand so did every other
director
and i really loved how jim and the other
directors you know gave me that
free kind of thing like it's free like
incorporate certain things into my
scenes which is what i really love like
and i really love how we can be
cooperative and
kind of like teamwork and
yeah it's really fun having getting to
do that
yeah that's that's great that he let you
guys kind of be loose with your
portrayals and on set that's awesome um
do you now as an actor are you someone
who doesn't like to watch themselves
after on screen or will you watch the
whole show
um i'm not so much of an actor who likes
to watch myself on screen
but for this show because i
really feel like you know it was so
amazing how we
brought it to life i i've watched the
late episodes but you know i'm always
like criticizing my acting
of course of course yeah and i'm not a
big fan of watching myself
okay but you did it for this one you had
to because it's so good and you yeah
you're amazing everyone else is so
amazing
and everyone was so great you know
portraying their characters and you know
also the message that i want people to
take away from the show
is hope and optimism during dark times
like
covid is is a dark time and we really
need
that hope and optimism to you know push
through it
so that's what i really love about sweet
tooth you get that message of hope and
optimism and i also love
so the comic book was pretty dark but i
really loved how
jim and everyone who wrote the script
you know really changed it to make it
more of a family-friendly plot so more
families can watch it obviously some
children like me will need some parental
supervision
when watching it but yeah sure
so it's free for the whole family to
watch 100 and i think that's what's
going to just
bring so many people to it it's already
getting such an amazing response from
critics
how do you feel seeing that and then
also seeing your face on these big
billboards in like times square that's
got to be surreal right
yeah um you know getting to see my face
on billboards in times square is pretty
cool because
it's times square and it's a billboard
yeah it's so
amazing you know back to filming it's so
amazing
seeing all the hard work that everyone
put into the show when doing it
so efficiently and effectively during
coven 19
which was a tough challenge to you know
get through but
you know as on set i really loved how
the crew did such a good job
at you know following the safety
protocols while also staying focused on
their objective
i really love how we were all safe and
they followed all the rules and
you know before you got to said you had
to do the temperature check and there
were so many safety precautions
which was really good for everyone on
set to keep them safe and also outside
of set new zealand did such an amazing
job at handling coved
so i really feel like that was
really good of everyone on set how they
did their job so well while also
following the safety protocols
yeah and you you guys filmed with some
of it pre-covered and then some was
after right yeah so the first episode
was written well not written but we
filmed it when i was like nine years old
which was like two years ago two
right so that was way before coven like
these the dc comic was written back in
2009 way before covet ever started
so i thought it was pretty timely how
we're now filming the episodes two to
eight during coven
but episode one we that was pre-covered
and you know getting to
that switch was so um you know kind of
tricky having to get used to all the
protocols that we had to do
because normally i'm not used to it
because i never filmed the job during a
pandemic
or anything like that so getting to do
that was pretty tricky and a challenge
but
at the same time i really love how
everyone you know did such a great job
at handling it
sure now you know because everyone's
gonna it's gonna give you so much
attention the show and
people want to know more about you i'm
curious and one thing on my head is
you're so
talented as an actor at such a young age
is there someone you're getting
inspiration from is there an actor or
actress you look up to
well i looked up to every actor
and every actress you know because you
know i can take
so much like inspiration from them and
you know because they're all so talented
i learn different things from them and
that's what i really love you know
about movies tv shows and netflix
because you know netflix has such a
diverse range of movies
which is really good because you know it
helps me
really take away different things from
different shows which really helps me
during my acting
now is there anything speaking of shows
and netflix movies is there anything
recently you've watched that you could
suggest that maybe your fans like to
hear you're kind of into like any movies
or shows
a tv show that i've recently finished
was
ragnarok season two it's a pretty good
show and i love it but
you know sweet tooth is coming out june
4.
oh it has come out by the time you're
seeing this interview of course
but you know just watch sweet tooth
because it's pretty cool
oh hell yeah and um also too you know
you share on your instagram
he seems like you do a lot of fun stuff
like windsurfing frisbee very outdoorsy
are you also though someone who likes to
do like indoor hobbies like are you a
gamer at all is there anything you're
into like that
i am a gamer yes i am a gamer and i
love also playing the guitar inside my
house and
i love just having fun with my dog and
playing board games with my family like
my grandma and my grandpa and my mom
and some indoor hobbies i also like to
do is sometimes i like to just come up
with
different ideas for scripts in my head
so that way when i'm older you know i
can write different scripts
also in the future i do want to be a
director and a producer and a writer too
because i feel like that'd be very fun
to do yeah that's awesome and you
mentioned two guitar i think
you have those great videos you shred in
led zeppelin foo fighters
uh is that something you might want to
even take more seriously as your career
goes on maybe it's music as well
yeah maybe i could perform different
songs on stage
or maybe i could perform a soundtrack
for sweet tooth
which would be pretty cool i love it um
you know
do you think though how many if you
could
predict having someone who's read the
comics and being in the show itself
how many seasons do you think they could
do of this show like how do you think
this could be a long
running show yeah i think it could be
more than five seasons like
by the time i'm like an adult the show
could still be running
and i really feel like that'd be pretty
cool and
i really am hoping for season two and i
really hope that
everyone loves sweet tooth when they
watch it so well you know we can go back
to new zealand and film more of that to
you know entertain
our friends and everyone who's watching
it more to make them you know happier
and that's what i really love about
acting because you know you're making
people happier you're entertaining them
and you know getting that inspiration
from different actors
i really love that part of acting too
because you know it teaches me
so many things about acting and
different
aspects and sometimes when i'm on set
you know me and my i just make new
friends and you know i get to meet new
people that's what i also really love
about acting too
see look at that and it pays forward
because you're gonna inspire people
saying stuff like that
um and i think everyone's blown away
performance and the show
everybody make sure to watch sweet tooth
if you if you haven't already
watch it again watch it a bunch of times
it's on netflix
now um and you can watch christian just
kill it here in the lead as
gus thank you so much christian for
joining me and i hope to talk to you in
the future one day
thank you see you too